welcome to the scoops to this head video
playing Kampai Kampai is the name and
from the South America but away exactly
Venezuela no Colombia I cannot do that
right I cannot do that right okay so we
got a blue loop has chat Steinitz
variation I don't think that what I just
played is seven maybe objectively the
best line but I'm like this type of
Kings Indian structure of course I firm
as on a long time default player I have
some experience in those structures can
I'd like to gain some space on the Kings
side I haven't castled yet so I have
some flexibility yet can or still soon
as the right word still with my king
position i can even castle long if
they're there is a good moment for that
Queen g4 I need to cover cover f4 anyway
so this is a fine move I hope and it's
not so clear what the queen is doing
here I can play I can't play 95-year you
know that's not a bad move exchanging
Queens I know if it takes here and takes
on g5 he will exchange his bad bishop
but that will open the H file for me
which is quite nice now maybe you can
take and play f6f six yeah yeah that you
can do
okay so if i take it mmm she'll probably
must take it move like rock edge fibers
is mostly pointless yeah okay and now
we're playing this end game where white
has an advantage in space which is nice
until the King end up in play already
and one now okay I needed to take care
of the eff porn first night be fire firm
is an idea though okay rook d3m one pair
of rooks to exchange one pair of rooks
would be nice okay I'll do that first
and one possible way to regroup is
getting the night to III to f5 this type
of type of idea maybe yeah and then be
45 of course I will do this next I guess
yes okay so he's maybe getting the night
over 27 no 2 CH five how interesting
I can I can unknown IG 59 f 3 can take
only form which I forgot
that's bad yeah now black has Knight f3
to deform
wow that's not good yeah I need to get
this active active player quickly and he
could have played night h2o as well Wow
yeah I don't really have much of an
odometer I need to give away of two
kinky one that's not see too I really
forgot that efore was hanging every
night XD form I needed to play em and
save a safety move first okay here i can
play a forum I guess very important yeah
I think he probably should have taken
one night h2o instead of 94 was guess
the cleanest way to do it yeah politics
or oak chair Aponte exam the knight on
d4 now acer is really in a spot of
bother where it is going on it's taking
Wow yeah well now I'm an excellent shape
I only has night be five which is not
exactly a good place so f five now to UM
to cover form yeah let's just do that
not think about it too long
there are probably more than there's
probably multiple ways to to get a
really good position yeah he just could
have played night H to end i'm basically
toast i think we are 95 is the problem
with that I hope
and drew k 7 i'm and i can i can like
take it with a check okay i can take
here come and sorry night f7 i can take
if form kini 294 check King you one
night see to check amazing
don't tell me this isn't winning here
night f7f e4 I cannot believe it King
294 check I have no I have no place to
go time while I leches unbelievable
amazing simply amazing man and I can dig
up five and still it so it's continuing
my deaf seven I can just move for King I
doesn't it doesn't do much
yeah well he's got this offside night
still should be good for white but that
it didn't win instantly is still quite
unbelievable for me I probably just i
just calculated nonsense I'll see that
in the postmodern town he cannot really
defend myself if I give the trick maybe
better checking op8 trying to I am yeah
this is quite good the night has no good
spot check check yes was very lucky or I
will be a very lucky victory check and
listen again blundering stuff but quite
quite amazing Jack Black for fits on
time yeah let's just check this again I
mean my problem was only here I always
thought okay he's going night g 5a
player three okay no problem the thing
is I overlooked that after this I cannot
play f3 because he just takes it and
wins instantly so instead of the night
moved to be too i need to play rookie 30
f3 now let's say here 95 f 3 and in this
position i can simply continue and i am
at least slightly better due to the
space advantage it's not the end of the
world for black but
I preserve something here and I was just
too late and recognizing that there is
this this tactical idea and after this
I'm just I'm just in terrible shape
really i mean i can defend it better 93
is a better move i mean this should have
lost instantly 2nite h2 after that I can
basically resign I mean it's not just
that I'll lose the exchange I lose f2
and the whole position breaks down this
is totally album and this is again again
interesting because my counter play on
d6 is quite substantial and it's not a
loss here and then this this is in fact
again great for me he had to take it
really something like that and now not
sure baby be 50 no I this is this is not
entirely clear I mean night h2 was
winning and much better but this is just
unclear and after he loud therefore I
mean this is a this should be a win
really I probably have to have done
something something bad here maybe I a4a
for first is the right one and then and
then this is in fact not yeah okay King
c4s winning much simpler when I mean
this this keeps keeps a huge edge but i
was still amazed that it isn't like
instantly winning okay black hand black
has no defense against the look invading
on the queenside together with this
space advantage bad King that this is
some win yeah quite remarkable really
we're very important to always calculate
the opponent's threats correctly I mean
I had seen the idea yeah it's obviously
wants to go to g5 but I didn't see
Knight takes e4 and and played this
paired 20 seconds I invested on so it's
not like I played it instantly
didn't think about it at all I just
blundered this idea and after that yeah
93 years is still something that I
should try here not quite sure why it
didn't occur to me this is in fact quite
okay still not not great but um if you
look at this I what if you look at this
I'm be offending f2 I had I hadn't
really seen night h2 only when I when
I'm with this well okay thanks for
watching